I'd known him for many many many many
years back when his kids were like their
his kids are in college now that really
bothers me senior almost in college and
that really bothers me that's how long
I've known this guy
um
um he he often actually introduces me
that's you know we're uh or a really
good relationship he's the type of
person when I text him some like life
news he'll call me to thank me to talk
to me about it which like really super
sweet and I just think that's really
speaks to who he is that he'll call you
like he doesn't text you back
congratulations like he'll call and like
hey what's going on and I really love
that about him
um so
that's my fun fact for him that he's a
sweet guy who like who cares about you
so if that please mark come on down
good afternoon everybody my name is Mark
Weissman uh thank you Jared for the kind
introduction uh we we you know we've
known each other for a long time and
obviously we try to you know make as
much fun as we can to each other with
and being respectful about it uh so I am
here today to talk to you about
um a couple of things that I'd love for
you to think about
um as you are going into your our
journey so I mean I hope probably I
think everyone in this room is in our
user I'm sure everyone in this room uses
other tools as well so uh the idea here
really spawned from many many things and
I'll get to that in a second but the the
the idea here is moving from this right
from your laptop or your workstation or
wherever it is that you're doing your
work into a
production environment and I'm using air
quotes because production can mean many
things
I'd like to do a quick uh just sort of a
survey here so
have who's written have who's ever
written in our script to be run in a
non-interactive way raise your hand
okay so actually a good number of you
good good
did it work the first time as planned
raise your hand if it did
ask me good for you
have you ever scheduled in our script to
run without human intervention
okay all right so we're I thought we'd
be I thought we'd be worse but good this
is great actually
um raise your hand if you actually have
in our script running in production
right now
okay very few fans so why uh we won't
get into the why uh because that's a
really complex thing and I only have 18
minutes left
so
um we're back
this was 2019 and uh my walk-up song was
a uh a customer song and I came and I
even did an impromptu horror with Jared
but we'll leave it at that
um who am I uh again I work for
Microsoft I am a senior Cloud Solutions
architect been at Microsoft for five
years I was working mostly with Federal
customers I I switched to a different uh
different industry so working with
financial customer services industry I
help customers use Azure for our data
science machine learning analytics uh
workflows
right now I'm doing a stint in the Azure
machine learning product team which has
been really cool so I'm working within
the the PM program management product
management that I don't know what the P
really stands for but uh it's been
really great and I'm going back into the
field at the end of the month at the end
of the year so again I teach here at
Georgetown so a couple of my fellow
colleagues are here uh fellow students
I'm not going to call anyone out hi Zev
um
uh and uh co-founder of data Community
DC you know I used to like our like
Jared runs the our Meetup in New York uh
I used to do that here with a budget and
a bunch of other folks for a long long
time uh you know life gets in the way uh
move on to other things uh we're trying
I'm talking to Alex about maybe
restarting kind of having events and
just we want new blood we want folks to
come and volunteer and maybe help us
like rekindle it because frankly like to
me the Meetup was sort of what really
brought me into the r world uh that's
where I met Jared that's where I got
into the data science uh that's what I
learned about Big Data it's been just
phenomenal so that
the inspiration for today so I'm doing
the work I'm doing right now within the
Azure machine product so interestingly
the work I'm doing within the Azure
machine learning product team is working
on making on improving our documentation
and um examples for our
specifically for our a lot of customers
are asking for it
um anyone here ever uses Azure machine
learning just out of curiosity
no one wow okay yeah all right we can
talk later
um anyway the idea is we're just
revamping that I'm actually working on
that so as I was thinking about this and
also also over the years of me teaching
I teach a big data class which you
really need to figure out how to you
know interface with systems and stuff
like that that's sort of the inspiration
for this talk so
our work has changed right as data
scientists when we talked about data
science 10 years ago we talked about the
famous Drew Conway Venn diagram right
who's I'm sure you've all seen this
before yeah
so in this context really it was more
about perhaps machine learning like
building a model like figuring out what
was going on with your data that sort of
thing the world has changed we we live
in this world now and as you've seen
from the previous talks today everyone
is talking about production everyone's
talking about Docker everyone's talking
about a document building you know it's
a team thing you don't work in Asylum
you may if you're in a basement
somewhere but you don't right I mean you
are part of a team uh what tasks within
data science you're doing I mean that
can be a whole day discussion so I'm not
going to get into it but the point is if
you want to live in this world
you have to think differently about your
code
let's not even get into mlaps this is
the conceptual model for ML Ops which is
abstracted by a lot of the different
platforms
the point is what I'm going to talk
about today I think is really really
important because of the things I've
said before number one I think it'll
make you a better programmer right
number two it just it will make again
well your code will be better but you
will just learn how to think more
strategically about the work that you're
doing and how it moves on you you don't
live in a vacuum I hopefully not
um
but the work that you're doing as a data
scientist so they'll say you're building
a model right but that model is a
scoring model for some sort of
application well that model needs to
live somewhere has to go somewhere and
it's part of it's a cog at the end of
the day
what we do in data science are just
different cogs of a big machine
yeah
everyone agree with me good
so but it's really really important
what is production again air quotes
anyone know where this is from
raise your hand if you know what this is
oh wow uh okay only a few so this is
this is a famous scene from the I Love
Lucy show where they they're working as
Factory workers and they uh instead of
packing chocolates they're actually
eating it it's hilarious
um
so again what is production production
really is different things to different
people
um so let's look at this right and I'm
glad many of you have Scripps working
production but you know let's think back
to that scenario where you say okay I'm
trying to run this and it didn't work
the first time so I have a super super
duper important business stuff whatever
script that I wrote right
in my on our studio or Visual Studio or
whatever you use and then I go and I run
it from the command line and then you
get an error
yeah
or maybe you get another error I mean
these are typical R ER errors right
there's nothing sort of glaring about
this I mean if you use R you know it's
an R error I can't go and think of the
bucket but it's not very descriptive
right if you try to run this into
production and some like some
orchestrator calls this it will error
and it won't run
so what happened you don't know but this
is just one aspect of going into
production and again what is production
production really is different things to
different people
what do you need so when you think about
the code especially as you're thinking
about moving into production Jared I
think Jared hit Jared talked about a
whole side of production that is just
even beyond the scope of what I'm
talking about
but production just means running a
script in a not in a in a automated way
like without human intervention and that
will run probably somewhere else and to
be able to do that successfully right
and to avoid errors you have to sort of
think Beyond many Scopes so you have to
think about logging you have to think
about error handling so try catch you
have to think about replicable
environments so uh packages your
libraries like things that you practice
on Docker credentials uh logging with
interpretable messages right like kind
of error messages that make sense
parametrized scripts which is what I'm
going to focus on in a few minutes
metadata right and then obviously
Network and security which is is part of
the whole stack but I mean obviously
we're not we're not even going to go
there right now but
um you know really if you're going to
run our in our script in sort of a
scheduled triggered deployed somewhere
else in a remote server you need to
think about ways and strategies to write
your R code in production so I talked
about a couple things but what about the
code itself
right what do we do about the code
so you have many options here to the
rescue World Cup fans in here
okay so there you go
um what's the score who's playing today
I don't even know uh so I'm gonna just
very at a very high level talk about
these uh these these two techniques one
um one's called functional programming
raise your hand if you've heard of of
that term before
okay so most of you have what about meta
programming
okay so great so awesome and then
obviously DIY which is sort of a mix of
both it's not really either but
um well good news
you probably have been doing both of
these in R Without Really knowing that
you were doing it now I'm not going to
get into the the um foundational aspects
of what function like true functional
programming is and what because there
are many uh computer you know
programming languages that that do that
the thing with r is R is sort of it's
not a pure functional language it's not
a pure declarative like R is sort of
multimodal and you can do all sorts of
things but if you've been using the Tidy
verse for for a good amount of time
which I'm pretty sure ever I don't know
most everyone in here is I think I don't
know raise your hand if you are
okay most of you
um
the Tidy verse just gives you a lot of
these tools already in but I'm going to
just give you a refresher of what these
are just so that or at least mention
what they are and just so that you
understand how to think about your code
as you're doing this so again two ideas
right functional programming and meta
programming and if you go to a Hadley's
Advanced r on the website I forgot to
put in the URL there actually are
chapters on this there's a whole slew of
resources
um I actually have been reading a really
good book it's called rocking functional
programming it's a Manning book
um it's the examples are in Scala which
is probably a pure functional language
than R is in that sense but
um I think from a conceptual standpoint
it's just a really it's a really good
read
um so functional programming what is
functional programming so it's really
it's a combination of things it's it's a
way of writing code it's uh it's a oh oh
it's a paradigm right I don't think
there is like functional program in the
like pure true functional programming
I'm just going to keep it at a higher
level sort of let's talk about this in
the r sense some of what we do when we
do tidy verse right
um especially with better programming or
because R has what's called non
non-standard evaluation like all of that
allows it to do you can do functional
programming much easier also meta
programming much easier but it this
comes from Lambda the idea of functional
comes from functions right from Lambda
calculus so the idea that you have a
function some black box in the middle
you give it an input you get an output
if you give it the same input you should
get the same output you should not get
different outputs
right we don't want to do this
you know we don't want to we don't want
to do the same thing over and over again
unexpective results right good
um so here are just three different kind
of quickly uh three ideally pure
functions and I'm using pure in quotes
again because I think it depends on the
context but
um
so the first one adding two integers
function a and I have this functional
add function A B A plus b the second
character the second one find the first
character I give it a string uh and I
sub string right S11 this is actually
our code and then the last one is divide
two integer so the tenets of pure
function so functional programming uh
goes with the idea of using what's
called Pure functions which is a
function should return a single value a
function should only use its arguments
it shouldn't use anything from your
global environment right everything that
the function needs has to be passed into
the function and the third is that does
not mutate existing values again uh that
that's a little bit more complex but
let's look at this for a second
there is one last thing
code shouldn't lie
okay
I don't even know where this is from I
guess it's from a Disney movie but
what
oh God okay fine I just gave myself away
I've seen bits and pieces of that movie
not never the whole thing the point I
need to I need it's on my it's on my
watch list
it's on my watch list but guys hey I
work I teach and I have a family so my
Netflix viewing time is limited
um all right let's look at these
functions again are these functions
lying
are they
the first one
so add function A and B now again I got
these I took these examples from the
grocking book which came from Scala
Scala is a statically typed language
which means that you actually have to
specify the data types going in the data
types going out we don't do that in R we
should
right because that will make us better
programmers because that will ensure
that the data that's going into our
function is treated the right way right
and not a character so if I actually did
add and I said three and I did well R
does a bunch of stuff for us right if I
give it a if I give it a um if I give it
a real number and an integer it will
co-host everything to real right uh yeah
exactly so it does coercion for us like
implicitly we don't have to do that
other languages don't we have to do that
ourselves so that's one area where ours
look a little tricky although you can
apply these ideas R does a lot of stuff
for us without us really understanding
so it's really important that when you
write functions
use error handling and make sure that
the types do data type checks when the
your data you know whatever your
parameters going into the function are
coming in so that the function does the
right way because if not you're going to
get different results and obviously
you're going to violate the whole
functioning programming paradigm so the
first one possibly the second one you
know again in R if I do this and I give
it a blank if I does it give us back a
string it will if I give it a blank
string I get an empty string back in
Scala you don't you get an error and the
third one here obviously if we give it
an N A or something we will get an error
but the point is the idea is is that
there is more to meet there is more than
meets the eye especially in R because of
a lot of the type conversions and so
coercions and other things that R does
for us so as you're writing your code
make sure you know what your parameters
are
meta programming
um the definition from Wikipedia it says
it's basically a programming technique
that lets compute that your data is
programs that get converted into other
programs so we we probably do a lot of
that
um without even knowing if you use what
is it like DB player like DB player
converts d-player code to SQL for
example you can generate yaml you can
generate Docker so that's just all meta
programming but this is also there's
also meta in the sense of like passing
parameters into your tidy verbs I'm not
going to get into the the whole thing
because that's sort of a bigger thing
but we are doing that and those two
things like functional and
and meta programming I think ours really
Flex is really
what's the word it's great for that it's
great for that and it allows you to be a
lot flexible with your programming but
flexibility also perhaps May introduce
error so you have to find that balance
right between flexibility and and kind
of I'm writing let's call it production
level code whatever your production
might be it could be like taking it in a
USB stick doing sneaker net right
walking it to a a sensor out in the
field that's collecting data I don't
know what production is but you know to
each their own
so how do we prepare our code for
production
you should this this is again this is uh
this is sort of my opinion but
um you should think of like take your
interactive script right which typically
you write and you say you know set
working directory or use here or you
create a pat you know you create a um
a project which sort of bundles
everything for you but rather than using
that like parametrize everything that
goes into your script because that way
you can call that script externally
right and and send this so it's
basically you take a whole level of
abstraction up right your script is a
function and your script takes some
inputs and produces outputs ideally the
same inputs will produce the same output
so your whole script should be you know
have this idea of functional programming
but then you can send metadata to that
script right and then you can run the
same script over so example it's like
say you're running a bootstrap or you're
building a bunch of models for you know
large data sets or a many model scenario
where you have different you know
thousands of different groups and you
have to build you're still you're
running a regression on all these
different groups you can scale that out
easily you just send the right you know
the piece of data right and again I'm
not thinking about like you can do that
on your machine obviously if it's if if
you have enough space and memory and all
that but if you're doing thousands or
hundreds of thousands of simulations you
probably you're probably going to do
this either in a cluster or in a
kubernetes or Docker environment
government or in an ml Ops platform
whatever it is
here are some packages that will help
you with this the first two are two ones
that I've learned about recently
especially as I'm working on updating
our our documentation these are just
ways that we're going to show you how to
take in our script and be able to run
that on Azure machine learning for
example so the first one is called
carrier and carrier
I still don't fully understand carrier
but it basically takes it it
encapsulates a function with all of its
meta it's not just like taking an object
and saving it and serializing it does a
lot more so you can replicate that
elsewhere
up parse now you can you know R has the
um I forget it's like it's the args
function which you can pass in command
line scripts because typically when you
run these scripts in some kind of
production environment it's run via it's
using our script which is the command
line execution for R and you pass in
parameters right to the script so our
opt parse is based on the python up
parse package which allows you to you
know how in Python you type in like
python script and then like Double Dash
parameter you know how you yeah so it
allows you to do the same thing with an
R script it's actually pretty neat
um Qs is one I learned about recently so
Qs is called quick serializing it's
really instead of using like doing save
RDS there you use the Qs because you're
going to actually save multiple objects
from your workspace into a single RDS
file and it does it very very quickly
that ever we heard some talks about
better before I'm still not fully
familiar with it I know it's mlops-ish
related one thing I read about vetiver
which I thought was really neat is that
vetiver can generate a Docker file for
you
and it can also generate a plumber
script for you so think of meta
programming right and then yaml so you
can generate yaml because typically when
you run these things in production
you're going to need some sort of yaml
script which is your job description so
you can generate that yaml with r as
well and obviously everything you do in
the Tidy verse whether it's tidy verse
or the the time series stuff tidy verts
and the Tidy models and I love the idea
of the Tidy verse because everything is
a data frame or a table and then you
know you can use the five basic verbs of
a tibble to basically manipulate
everything else which I find it
extremely useful and extremely easy
and I have one minute to go uh up parts
this is an example of up parse so what
you do is you you load the library you
do this and this and essentially you can
actually Define the uh what how you're
done because everything's going to come
in this text right from the command line
so here you can actually I mean you
could do coercion like as dot something
but this is much more flexible because
you can actually it's going to check for
type as well and then what happens is
here's this is what single script uh
it's called Data file and the idea is
that as this is if this is part of my
script right I am going to pass in the
path that's going to be read in okay
that's just one example and then carrier
like I said it sort of encapsulates
everything so here again this is using
species right we train this is the model
yeah we're not doing the splits whatever
but the predict we're creating the
predictor and you're creating this so
it's basically packaging all the stuff
up into into one environment
to wrap up just to um
talk about ml you know why why all this
well because again I am writing examples
for our in production using ml Ops right
and and Azure um Azure machine learning
so
ml Ops is really big and as you've seen
right it really takes into consideration
all sorts there are many people involved
in lops right people with different
skills and people that are you doing
different things but this is how we
Microsoft think about ml Ops uh again
you have on the left side like kind of
the data part right the prototyping then
the middle part is
um collaboration and then the last part
here on the right hand side is actually
operation
operationalization how many syllables
seven six five uh anyway
um data science lifecycle I think we've
all seen this
and again you know kind of the there has
been there has been some talk out in the
world about how we are not really
supporting R that's not true we are no
I'm serious
um
we're working on it that's all I can say
uh these are some of the references I
used for today so that's the book I told
you rocking functional programming it's
really good this is just the website
that we have this thing called the ml
Ops technical paper
um some of the are in production stuff I
uh I saw from uh this guy in some of
this talks there's a link and obviously
had these things uh Advance again so
thank you very much